من الفضاء مشاهدينا الى الفضاء ايضا
وانجاز سعودي اخر اختراع لطالبه سعوديه
شغوفه بعلم الفضاء منذ صغرها حصد
الميداليه الذهبيه بمعرض ايتكس للاختراعات
في ماليزيا الطالبه السعوديه يوم
العتيبي ترجمه مشروعها الى قمر صناعي
يستطيع الكشف المبكر عن حرائق الغابات
باستخدام تقنيه
الاختراع بدات منذ العام الماضي والان
دخلت الخطوات العمليه لاطلاقه في الفضاء
بعد اجراء الاختبارات المطلوبه اليوم
سنستضيف المخترع الشاب الصغيره يمن
العتيبي لنتعرف معها على تفاصيل اكثر عن
هذا الاختراع الفائز بالذهب
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا معنا الان من جده المخترعه
الشابه
العتيبي اهلا بك من معنا والف الف مبروك
على فوزك بهذه الجائزه
خليني بس ابلش معاكي يوم من اول اشي شعورك
باحراز هذه الجائزه لك يعني
لبلدك السعوديه التي تمثليها
اكيد انا فخوره جدا بهذا الانجاز خصوصا
لانه اخذ وقت طويل على ما اني اجهزه
واعرضه في محفل عالمي زي ايتكس وبعد ما
وجدت الاقبال الكبير وقدرته لخدمه العالم
بحصولي بالجائزه الذهبيه في مجالي وايضا
جائزه المخترع الشاب من مواطنه الابتكار
كانت لحظه سعيده جدا طيب خليني اسال ليش
هذا الاختراع
وحبك للفضاء من وين جاء
من صغري كنت منبهره بالفضاء والمركبات
الفضائيه وكيف انه لا حدود له وانا جدا
شغوفه في بعلم الفيزياء ولذلك بدات اقرا
وابحث
باستمرار وكانت اسرتي تدعمني بشكل دائم من
خلال توفير المصادر والبيئه المناسبه لكي
اتعلم اكثر وعندما صدر الامر الملكي
لتاسيس الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء في عام
2018 هذا زاد حماسي بشكل كبير فبدات اني
اسس نادي لطلبه الثانويه المهتمين في علم
الفضاء وهندسه المراكب الفضائيه ومن خلاله
بدات انشر مقالات لهذا المجال طيب خلينا
نفهم اختراعك اكثر يا يوم انت هو عباره عن
قمر صناعي يطلق في الفضاء
ويتنباؤ وبقدر انه يكشف عن حرائق كيف
بيعمل بالضبط يعني ومن سيستفيد منه تحديدا
القمر الصناعي هذا
يقيس كميه الاشعه التي تصدر من الشمس الى
الارض بهدف قياس الحراره وايضا كميه
الهيدروكربون التي تبعث في الغابات لكونها
احدى الاسباب الرئيسيه في بدء الحرائق وعن
طريق ذلك يستطيع هذا القمر الصناعي ان
يفرض توقعات لحرائق قادمه من خلالها يتم
حمايه الارواح وحمايه البيئه متى راح يكون
انطلاق هذا القمر ويعني يكون على ارض
الواقع لا مو على الارض راح يكون بالسماء
وفي الفضاء
البروتوكولات حتى تكون جاهزه للانطلاق
وانا اعمل الان لاكماله على افضل وجه
وايضا اطلع اني اكمل العمل عليه في دراستي
الجامعيه واتمنى ان اراه على ارض الواقع
قريبا باذن الله والله الموفق طيب يوما في
هذا اليوم اللي بيشهد انه اول سيده عربيه
وهي سعوديه ريانه برناوي تنطلق الى الفضاء
وطبعا مع زميلها ايضا
على القرني علي مش عادل
طيب يوما هل في عندك طموح بانه في يوم ما
مش بس القمر الصناعي اللي انت اخترعتيه
راح يكون او ينطلق الى الفضاء ولكن انت
ايضا كرائده فضاء
عندك الحلم طبعا رحله رواد الفضاء
رحله رواد الفضاء ريانه وعلي هو حلم
بالنسبه لنا خصوصا لجيلي انا كمان وان
وكمان المركبه اللي ينطلقوا منها الصاروخ
فالكون ومركبه يمكننا اعاده تدويرها في
المستقبل هذا كمان كان جدا شيء مبهر لنا
حاليا
والابحاث العلميه الذي سيقومون فيها ونحن
جدا فخورين ممتنين لدولتنا الغاليه بدعم
لمثل هذه الجهات بلا شك ان السعوديه حتكون
رائده فيها
اتمنى عليك طبعا ان تحتفظين بهذا اللقاء
ان شاء الله لما تكونين رائده فضاء
وتسعدين الى الفضاء نكون اول ناس تنبئنا
لك ان شاء الله بهذا المستقبل الباهر
الذهب للذهب دائما والف مبروك لمن العتيبي
شكرا جزيلا وان شاء الله الخير بقبال كل
التوفيق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات